hey everybody and welcome to reality
check space exploration there's not a
sci-fi fan in the world who hasn't
dreamed of hopping into a spaceship and
then taking to the stars you might say
it's the final frontier
and speaking of frontier the
cambridge-based development team are the
creators of elite dangerous this third
installment in the seminal gaming series
allows players to play in and explore
the entire of our Milky Way galaxy
that's right 100 billion star systems
your gaming fingertips you can even use
an oculus rift headset to for full
immersion it's essentially like printing
your head directly in space except you
know without all the dying now a few
months ago I sat down with David Braben
he's the CEO of frontier and also the
core writer on the whole elite series
now I intended to speak to him about how
you create a game world that big and I'm
also what you could actually do in it
you know video gaming stuff but instead
we taught science for two hours and the
amount of it in this game completely
blew me away and I think it'll do the
same for you too so strap in charge up
your faster-than-light Drive and prepare
to jump
zipping around are gargantuan galaxies
in mere minutes is not something we can
currently do in real life hell it takes
around eight months just to get to Mars
one way our next-door neighbor planet
so obviously the science can't be
completely true to life so I asked David
where do you even start with a
predicament like this
one great lie which is one bitter
science that you sadly have to suspend
to make it a great game traveling faster
than light
we have the ability to travel at super
luminary speeds by essentially
contracting the world as part of this
hyperspace the distances are so big you
need to travel a huge speeds to be able
to cover them in a meaningful time once
you have that you can then explore the
galaxy without it exploring the galaxy
is a much much bigger charge I'm not
saying it's not possible but it's not
practical within a single human
lifetimes it brings that wonder space it
means we can have space being accurate
in all other respects you know the real
sizes of systems be really truly giant
properly orbiting each other and all
those things I mean even at the speed of
light the nearest star is over four
years away so that's that's a hell of a
gaming session so I think the point
really is you do need to do something
like this
okay no argument there everyone loves a
good lie anyway but where do you go from
there what is the key to creating a
really compelling science fiction I
think it has to be consistent and self
consistent so everything else is as
scientifically accurate as you can make
it no artificial gravity none of that
sort of thing our space stations rotate
to give you perceive gravity by several
people force you know and they're
rotating at the right rate we've also
thought of how the ships dock because
actually you don't want to dock in one
gravity we think about point one gravity
is the best because it's still easy to
land you've got gravity to settle you
down but if you mess it up you things
happen a lot more less seriously it's
like landing on the moon or whatever but
also I could probably pick up a ton
weight I couldn't do that in a normal
you know so you could if you needed to
manhandle cargo around so that's why
it's at the center of the space station
center of the hub on this sort of
conventional what I call steering wheel
stations
what about getting around in real-life
distance is not the only limiting factor
for space exploration the results or the
matter of power so how does the world of
elite dangerous account for this while
maintaining a scientifically plausible
game world so one of the things that I
think is it's an assumption rather than
an abuse of science a theory we have
assumed that the ability to fuse
hydrogen is commonplace so we have
relatively cheap fusion reactions we've
know exactly how big they are how much
power you get from them because they are
actually in your space ships
so it's assumptions like that and NSA
well alright once we've got essentially
vast amounts of energy for free which we
have to assume anyway after spaceship
zipping around then would you bother
with so many other things you would do
you know hydroponics you can just do
some levels of light inside the station
very easily you know so it's all that
sort of lots of things follow naturally
so tell me what do you make of this
sci-fi world perhaps you're already
exploring the Milky Way in elite
dangerous or maybe you're worried that
some of the scientific accuracy might
get in the way of some other fun either
way let me know in the comments down
below or by tweeting directly at me at
Camp four as Rob I'll be back next week
in fact next year for more reality check
see you then